Hey guys, Pete here. HBO released a new
featurette for the upcoming Watchmen
series and there's a lot of interesting
new footage. Watchmen is gonna premiere on
Sunday October 20th at 9 p.m. on HBO
which hopefully means that promotion for
the show is going to ramp up at this
point. in the featurette we hear from
Damon Lindelof and the cast about the
show's themes which reinforce a lot of
the ideas that those of us who've been
watching closely have come up with but
what got me most excited was the new
footage which they sandwiched in between
the things we'd already seen in the
previous trailers. today I'm gonna do a
top 10 video about the ones that jumped
out at me and after we get through the
list I'll discuss the interview footage
and what it might mean. this will contain
spoilers for The Watchmen graphic novel
and its ending so if you're still
working your way through that you might
want to come back to this after you've
finished. now let's jump into the list.
Number 10 is this shot of what looks
like a time machine? we can only
speculate as to what's going on in this
shot or when it's taking place. the first
time I watched my impression was that
this is in the present timeline, that
this was probably Adrian Veidt in the
basement of his castle, and that he had
created a working time machine. when you
look a little bit closer though
everything in this room looks to be from
the past. the chalkboard, baby carriage,
and bathtub that you can't help but see
would be antiques in our modern world.
more than that though the construction
of the machine itself doesn't look
modern. the way it's riveted together
and the gauges and levers sticking out of
it makes me think this machine was built
sometime in the past. speaking of that
Number 9 is this shot of what clearly
looks like it comes from a timeline in
the past. in previous trailers we had
some shots that hinted that part of the
story takes place in the far past and
this shot seems to confirm that
conclusively. every detail screams, "hey,
this isn't in the 21st century!" and to my
untrained eye at least it looks to be
pre 20th century. what these characters
are doing here isn't clear all we can
see is that they built some sort of
contraption. the far past, contraptions,
and the fact that both characters are
wearing knee high leather boots could
connect this with the previous shot I
talked about, but that would just be a
guess. it's worth paying attention to the
fact that
Jeremy Irons is wearing clothing that
looks similar to the character in front
of the time machine in the interview
that looks like it is taking place
during the filming of these far past
scenes though. Number 8 is another
flashback and this is something that
actually happened in real history - the
Tulsa Race Riot of 1921. remember that
the alternate history of the Watchmen
universe most likely diverged from our
history in the late 1930s when the first
costumed adventurer
hooded justice put on a costume to fight
crime. so, its history is the same as our
history up until that point. during the
TCA we learned that the pilot episode
opens with a depiction of those riots
and in this featurette we get a sense of
what that will look like. if you're not
familiar with this historical event I
would recommend googling it before the
first episode airs because it's worth
learning about. Number 7 is a nice
callback for fans of the comic series
the Nite Owl glasses that we see Regina
King with in this shot. the original tech
was designed by Dan Dreiberg AKA Nite
Owl II. he was an original character who
was still alive at the end of the
graphic novel and we still aren't sure
if his character will make an appearance
in the HBO series. the technology he
developed definitely will though as we
see here and with the airship that is at
the very least based on his creation
Archie. I talked about this in my Easter
eggs video so I won't go into it again
here but what stands out about the
glasses shot is the framing and the look
on Angela's face as she takes them off.
whatever she's looking at is obscured
even though it takes up most of the
screen and I'm really excited to learn
what's going on here. Number 6 is this
exchange from the character that Nite Owl
fell in love with at the end of the book
Silk Spectre. Jean Smart has been
confirmed to be playing the costumed
adventurer in the modern-day timeline
where she now works for the FBI and we
get some insight into how she operates.
this clip was slipped into a trailer on
HBO Portugal about a week ago so it's
not brand new but it is a window into
how this well-known character has developed.
we see the new characters Red Scare and
pirate Jenny pull someone they have in
custody out of a van. Silk Spectre aka
agent Laurie Blake asks if his civil
rights are being violated
only to change her tune and say she was
just kidding and actually doesn't care.
Number 5 is the introduction of Hong
Chau's character who was rumored to be
playing a key role with the name of Lady
T. we had a quick glimpse of the actress
in previous trailers but here we get a
better look at her and some dialogue to
go with it. we see her handling an ornate
hourglass and she says, "don't interrupt,
we're getting to the good stuff." the room
she's in could be Ozymandias' castle
based on what we've seen so far but
there's nothing I can see that confirms
it other than it's like a rich guy's
house. it could be any rich guys house
but either way the character looks
interesting and I'm curious to see how
she fits into the story. and, the
hourglass is super cool looking but I'm
not sure exactly what's going on with
that. Number 4 is this shot of Angela
walking down this crazy-looking hall.
this doesn't immediately stand out as a
location we've seen in any of the
previous teasers. the way the door slides
open makes it look somewhat futuristic
if not just modern. Regina King and
Lindelof both hinted at the show taking
big turns as far as what you think you
know and the look on her face as she
goes down this hall makes it seem like
her character might be experiencing that
same type of feeling right here. I'm
gonna cheat for number 3 and say
basically every shot of Ozymandias in
this trailer. I didn't think there was
any doubt that Jeremy Irons was playing
the character from the original comics
but I guess if there was the closed
captioning on the Twitter version of the
featurette laid that to rest. but really,
every new shot of him we get here
ratchets up the mystery of what's going
on with the character. we see him in a
shot that looks like he could be present
at the funeral scene that we've seen so
many times, one where he might be
standing in front of a time machine or
if not then probably something related
to Dr. Manhattan that may or may not
exist in the past, and an interview shot
of him where it looks like he could be
hanging out in the actual past, and it
all just makes you wonder what he's been
up to since he killed millions of people
with a squid in New York City at the end
of the original comic book. we can't
overlook the fact that in the comic-con
trailer we saw a newspaper headline that
said he'd been officially declared dead,
and I don't know you tell me what you
think he's up to because it's excitingly
mysterious. I guess that's the best way I
could describe it. Number 2 is the
better look we get inside
Looking Glass' interrogation chamber. we
know from the casting description that
Looking Glass is a top interrogator and
behavioral scientist, that may also be a
bit of a sociopath. we've had a few
glimpses of this chamber with the
wraparound screens where he conducts his
interviews wearing the reflective mask
and the new footage gives us a clearer
look at the interior. if I'm not mistaken
the man sitting across from him is the
same guy we see Angela attack in the
camper. this thing is shaped like a
saucer almost. it's got these crazy
cameras mounted all around the walls,
it's got screens that wrap all the way
around. we've seen some of the imagery
that he's showing when he's talking to
people - I mean it's just an
interesting kind of thing that he has
going on here so once again my curiosity
is just really piqued at this. and the
Number 1 most interesting new shot
from The Watchmen HBO featurette is this
shot of Looking Glass. in it we see a  blue
light flash and then an orb falling
through the ceiling onto the floor.
Looking Glass is carrying a gun and he's
not wearing his mask. there's a couple of
cameras set up and it looks like there's
church pews there. the blue light gives
the scene a Doctor Manhattan kind of
feel, and well, the thing passes through
the ceiling without making a hole in it.
honestly I have no idea what's going
on here with this and that's precisely
why it landed on the top of my list. let
me know in the comments what you think
this thing is and what's happening in
this scene because I've been looking at
it all day and I haven't come up with a
good idea based on what we've seen
related to this story so far.
this featurette was definitely a nice
addition to the trailers we've already
seen. I don't think there were many
surprises in the way they described the
themes in the interviews from my point
of view. I have been reading and
dissecting everything related to the
show though and I imagine this could
hook a lot of people who haven't been
doing that so far hook them in. it all
sounds good as far as I'm concerned
twists, turns, hard to identify the genre,
how we as a society feel about heroes -
most notably people who wear masks and
fight crime...
sign me up for all those things for sure.
there was a lot of talking masks here. we
get confirmation that the police wear
masks because that protects them and
their families when they're not at work.
it sounds as though agent Blake is
talking about how things got messed up
in the past where you couldn't tell who
was good or bad because everybody was
wearing masks. Damon Lindelof does
mention that the show will honor the
original book but they also made it so you
don't have to read it to understand the
story which makes sense because they
want to appeal to a broad audience and
the book is more than 30 years old at
this point. personally I would still
recommend reading it though because the
amount of callbacks and Easter eggs is
nothing to shake a stick at.
while I'm sure it'll still work as a
standalone story it seems like it would
be a lot more fun to watch if you're
able to pick those things out in real
time. of course I guess you could just
watch my videos and let me do the heavy
lifting for you because I will
definitely be pointing all that stuff
out in my recaps. I mentioned the
seventh Cavalry in my last video so you
can check that out if you want to hear a
little bit more about them. I think it
looks pretty balanced and pretty
interesting and how the characters are
set up. obviously they're going to be the
bad guys but we aren't promised that
there's going to be some magical
solution that's going to be like a
superhero movie where everything gets
resolved and you know the right thing
happens at the end the make us all feel
good. I really don't think that's in
store for us. the fact that they're
opening with the riots which is not that
long in the past but definitely in the
past as far as the area where they're at
is interesting. the fact that these guys
wear masks that look like Rorschach
which definitely you know is probably
tied to his journal getting out is also
very interesting and like I said I mean
Ozymandias where's the guy been at
what's he been doing how is he involved
what's going on right now and yeah I
mean there's so many questions it looks
really good I'm really excited I hope
you'll decide to watch this show and
watch my videos to go along with it
because I think we're in for a good ride
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already like I said I'll
definitely be following this throughout
the season doing weekly videos thanks
for watching I will talk to you soon